[Music]
hello and welcome to the beyond us
series by the institute of art and ideas
my name is
bernardo castro and my name is fred
matzer in this series we are exploring
four concepts that underpin
and define the modern world knowledge
competition language and growth
and in each episode we're joined by a
leading thinker to help us and hopefully
you
see each concept in a new light
this is the third episode of the series
and today we are talking on
language perhaps the most useful of
human faculties
language allows us to communicate vital
information
about the external world and to organize
social
interaction but we often have difficulty
using language to convey the inner world
of our conscious experience
here to discuss the nature uses and
limitations of language with us
is renowned british philosopher of
language jennifer hornsby
welcome jennifer hello bernardo hello
fred
it's it's good to have been invited to
this it's a pleasure to have you here uh
jennifer to to tackle this big topic
um we have a challenge because we are
going to be using language to talk about
language itself and we want to make the
conversation
more general we want to explore the
nature of language what it is what it is
not
how it relates to to human human
consciousness how it relates to our
world view
um and and for the followers of the
beyond us
series they will know that towards the
end of each episode we
like to relate the concept that we are
discussing
to to society at large to the moment we
are living through
um and ask ourselves what might the
future bring
in that regard so i'll start with a
general question
that appeals not only to your philosophy
expertise
but to your wisdom as an experienced
human being
and the question is the following to
what extent
is language really a description
of an objective reality of an objective
state of affairs
and to what extent does it actually
create a sort of linguistic
reality tunnel in other words
a kind of of illusion what do you think
about this
you speak of language as a description
but i think it's a user of language who
describes things
but would the linguistic construct be
truly just a description
of objective states of affairs or is it
as much a reflection
of of the that hood or of who
that describes uh the world
in other words uh is is
are descriptions in language really
objective
and neutral or do they capture actually
a subjective point of view a sort of
idiosyncratic reality tunnel so to say
i think of any language as a shared
thing
so it's not as it were just the speaker
who's coming out with some words
whose attaching concepts to what one
might call things in the world
um so if she says things
and thereby applies words to things
i think she's um achieved a record of
how things are
objectively if you like so you don't
think that our
use of extremely loaded
terms like um the first one that comes
to my mind is god
there are probably seven and a half
billion different definitions
of the word god but we don't preface
what we say
by attaching our particular definition
first we just
use the words as
they have meaning to us and that meaning
may not be entirely
shared now god of course is a difficult
case i mean i think
if i use the word it depends whom i'm
speaking to
quite how i think of the word is being
understood
because what one wants to achieve in
communication is a shared understanding
the speaker says it and the hearer hears
it
and they um now both know what the
speaker said
so if i was speaking to a theist i'm
sure i would
use the word god on the assumption
that it wasn't the case that god didn't
exist if we if we listen to the newscast
at eight o'clock
information is conveyed to us in
language do you think that reflects a
more or less objective state of affairs
or is that
too um highly subjective in essence
i hope so i mean it will depend a bit on
what news channel
i might be listening to whether i'm
prepared to think that i'm learning how
things are in some other part of the
world
what happened yesterday in parliament as
it might be
but um yeah um
i don't know what hangs on calling those
things objective parts of the world
i mean i think if this is what actually
happened in parliament and that's what
i'm told on the news
then i'd come to know something that i
didn't know before
if i'm told that in myanmar such and
such is happening now
because they might have a reporter there
then i think i learned something even
about the present
i'll share with you my own uh impression
and i'll be glad to hear your your
commentary on it
sometimes i i i am scared
that um our world view
things that we take to be objective
facts about reality out there what
reality
is how it behaves our relationship with
it
may reflect a lot more our own
linguistic
patterns of thinking and the linguistic
structure
of the way we think about the world it
can reflect as much about that
as it may reflect a objective state of
affairs like that and
every now and then i get caught with
this oh my god i think this goes
further than i would ever dare admit
that that we are living in in linguistic
reality tunnels
so to say which are given by what we
tell ourselves in
in their language regarding the nature
of the world and
and the states of affairs out there have
you ever had an impression like that
that you
suddenly get caught off guard i don't
think
i share your fear okay but
i mean that's partly because i think
that um language is that
which is something i share with others
as it were
so it's not as though there's me and my
language and it confronts this world
and maybe it doesn't confront it in
quite the way that i'd
always hoped not sharing your fear as it
were
um i'm sure freddie will try to
we want to take you more to the
subjective side of things you know
descriptions of
inner states of affairs like our inner
feelings but before we go there
um i don't want to insist too much and
beat a dead horse but
there have been studies studies showing
for instance that
our perception of colors may be
highly influenced by the words we have
to express the differences between
colors
so if your language has a richer color
palette in words
then you see more colors or the other
way around
like there are studies on on a tribe in
africa
that the tribe is able to discern a lot
more subtle differences in green
than westerners are and so happens that
their language has a lot more words for
green
than than our language has so would
these suggest
some sort of linguistic loading even in
our perceptions themselves or you don't
or you don't
give credibility to this kind of studies
because as grown-ups we've all learned
some particular human language some of
us are lucky enough to have learnt too
as it were and we make use of such
concepts as we've
acquired by virtue of learning language
and living in the world in which this
language is used
um but
um so and and maybe
the fact that we've failed to learn the
concepts which people who have
who can distinguish many shades of green
and have words for each of them
have learnt but i don't think that's a
handicap to their
knowing whether something is green as we
would use it in english
yeah so what you're saying
jennifer is also when you don't know
about it you don't
miss it and it only becomes
clear when a person that has that
nuances in language
and in observation in this case in
colors
that it cannot be shared on the level
with the other person that doesn't know
it
but perhaps by knowing it can learn it
no indeed many of us that
of us feel that language can't do
justice to
the inner world of consciousness and the
question is do we simply need better
words and sentences or will it this
always be
impossible what uh what do you think
i suppose i'm not inclined to think of
consciousness as an inner world
as if it were kind of something
separable from
the world of which we think we speak um
i mean i i maybe differ from many
philosophers in thinking this i know
some philosophers think
that um we could give a material
description of a person
and that wouldn't account for the fact
of her being conscious
so we've got to add something um in
order to say what consciousness is
um but you know i think there are human
beings
and they are conscious as it were and
that's just a fact about a speaker
that she's conscious conscious usually
of what she's saying
so i i don't think of consciousness as
attaching to an inner world
i should say i'm in saying that i'm not
um
attending to something that bernardo
said earlier which was connected with
knowledge specifically of oneself um
because i'm thinking as it were i'm
conscious of the world around me i can
tell you what's here
i'll i'll be conscious in so saying i'll
assume that you
consciously hear what i say um
that of course doesn't um
speak to the specific question of what
one knows of oneself
um which perhaps one's
particularly inclined to think of as
inner
[Music]
is it is it's more difficult you think
to establish commonality of meaning
and and an intent when it comes to our
inner world because when it comes to to
objective facts out there like if i
invent a word
for a house like the word house we can
establish commonality of meaning by
pointing to the house and saying
that's what we mean by house but if
you're feeling in a very particular way
it's difficult to point at that and say
this is what i mean
by the word sadness or despair
we have those words but isn't it more
difficult to establish this commonality
of meaning
when it comes to our own private inner
feelings
yeah you spoke of yourself as inventing
the word house i
i deny that you invented it i know what
it means
it's you know it's a word of english
which you used um and i
i think um there's a tendency to think
concerning any word that someone might
at some point
have stipulated what it means as it were
so a house means something with people
they see that people so and i'm going to
call that a house
um but that seems to me just wrong
i mean you know um
we grow up in the language which is
spoken around us
spoken probably by our parents and
carers and others around us
and insofar as we know what words mean
it's because we've come to know what
they mean through this
process of acquiring language so words
emerge
they are not merely defined they're not
merely defined i suppose that's
one thing i'm saying yeah i mean which
isn't to say that you can't for some
words
um want to give a definition of it and
someone who didn't know what a word
meant if they were fluent in language
you could use other words to enable them
to
deter to understand now what this word
which they haven't previously heard
had meant and continues to mean
which brings me to a topic pretty
prevalent in society today
um i mean in the world of you know
alternative facts
and and fake news um when we hear people
talking or saying something so often
we sort of zoom into the words we
analyze
what the person said and and
may we lose from sight when we do that
uh
what the person actually meant in other
words what is more important what has
been said
or the intention behind those words i
know that
when i'm talking to my girlfriend i'm
always looking for what she means
um but when it comes to to you know the
social games at large politics
economics the news we zoom into words
could language be misleading
um in that regard as a sort of a
a layer which expresses meaning but also
distorts meaning
i should say first i i don't think there
are alternative facts as it were
so i think um at least so far as what
we're apt to think of as factual
language
is concerned um
we can use sentences which state facts
or if we lie we might use
a sentence which precisely doesn't state
a fact so i'm not
um i i don't think i
um scrutinize
the news for instance um to
determine whether there might be some
alternative facts in here
i mean i like to think i rely on
reliable sources
and that by and large what i'll learn
are the facts as they are um
but you you're talking about
private conversations you want um to
know what your girlfriend means
and i take it that um i take it that
ordinarily she like anyone else in the
first instance means what she says
as it were but there's more to it than
that i mean why should she be saying
this
so there may be something which led her
to say what she did
which it's important for you as her
boyfriend
to come to know i think what i'm trying
to to get at
is what are the limitations of language
do we make too much
of what is said as opposed to what is
meant can language really describe
the full gamut of our inner experience
can language even describe
objective states of affairs in other
words i'm questioning
the perfection of the tool but this the
sense i get from you
is almost that language isn't even a
tool
it isn't even invented it is one
with objective states of affairs
would that be fair to say if that's what
you think i would i would ask you then
what makes you come to this rather
absolute conclusion
i i think nobody um knows the origins of
the first human language or would know
actually what
to say about whether such and such in
human history
if they could even know it constituted
the first human language
but i'm i'm thinking of language as as
you and i know it
um and we're both users of it
um it it does seem as though you're
um what's different between us
is my insistence that language is shared
that you know i don't have a language
all on my own
nor does your girlfriend have a language
all on her own
and you said actually at the very
beginning we're going to have to use
language to talk about language
well actually there's nothing else that
we can talk with
i mean of course we can express our
feelings for people other than by
talking
but uh if we're gonna talk then it's
language that we have to use
and um for the most part
we have conversations with people who
share our language
and us who understand what we say
as we mean it i mean there can be many
many hiccups
but uh well i i i see where you're
coming from i think my
my my view is colored by my own
experience i'm i i
i i'm forced to think daily in three
languages
uh and i often catch myself
thinking about the same thing
differently depending on
in which language i'm thinking so that
my thinking reflects the structure of
language in dutch in the dutch language
objects tend to come first and verbs go
out to the end
so it forces me to think through the
complete thing
i'm trying to get at before i say the
first word
in english the verbs come first so you
can immediately start saying something
before you thought it through
to the end and then portuguese is again
differently it's a language that has a
lot
more synonymous words but more
more nuanced so i see that happening
myself but
if i can ask you ask this question more
precisely
are you with noam chomsky that language
reflects
a universal grammar that is encoded in
our genes that we don't really invent it
that language is a reflection of how we
think and how we have to think because
we are human beings
there's an extent to which i agree with
chomsky
which i think possibly you don't agree
with them about
um i am apt to think that it's a
characteristic of um
human children that they will acquire
the language of those around them as it
were
and which chomsky will put by saying
that as an innate language module or
whatever
um he seems to
um think that this has a universality
which i might want to deny attaches to
it
because i think i mean he they acquired
the language of those around them
but of course the language of those
around them has been
formed because it's um it existed
for many years
in the context of the social practices
of those around them which might be
quite different from the social
practices of
of a typical person in the uk who speaks
english
um so i think i think there are things
that chomsk is out to say which i would
disagree with but i think the um
sort of inatism in chomsky is something
i
sort of agree with and perhaps you don't
no i actually agree with him i think
there is a universality to the structure
of our thinking
and i do think we we think in linguistic
terms
by using concepts symbols and
grammatical structures to weave those
together
uh in a in a sort of inner
inner narrative and i actually i even
think that we
often confuse reality with our own
inner narrative without even knowing
that you're confusing those
but uh maybe you'll ask fred fred any
comments yeah
i'm thinking what we started with
that jennifer said that language is
there to
to share with others and
i always say it's sharing of
information everything that expresses
itself
in form or that we can be connected with
through with our senses
and so it can you be used
in an authentic honest way
to express our thoughts and feelings
because it's not only thoughts that we
are connected with
but also that what coincides
what goes through the not rational part
but informs for example through feelings
which is not
so if we look at language and we look at
sharing and sharing information
language is part of it but it's also the
smell
it are gestures of the others so it's
it's one of the ways to bridge or to
disbridge or to disconnect
so yeah and often i think but this is
not part of the conversation
at a very early stage
we were babies we didn't have language
and we still
were in contact with our parents or
other babies and
we could just smell an apple without
knowing the concept of an apple because
we know how
the color was how it spelled how it felt
and
things like that so that often brings me
to the question
at what level does it serve us
isn't language sometimes a little bit
too dominant
too dominant over other ways of
information exchange because when i
connect with a baby
or even with a dog you know also with a
dog
i can go more or less to the heart of
the dog by connecting my own heart
and then it is beyond language
so yeah this is just not a question
perhaps it is a question it's more
reflection
that i'm getting now yeah i think the
question that comes to me when you said
that is
is there a world beyond language
in the sense that a world a world that
cannot be described in language
i think i'm tempted to answer that
question as you put it
no i mean i you and i fail to know
what the world is when it's something
indescribable i mean philosophers have
very different
um ways of using the phrase the world
i'm out to think
the world is there wherein we'll live
and indeed our dogs and all other little
things
live um but is there anything to that
world that cannot be said and yet
is the case people sometimes struggle
to say things they um
they there's something that they'd like
to say
and find it impossible to say
um i don't deny that that's a possible
phenomenon
but you think those things are
describable at least in principle
maybe that one ex one experiences
emotions
and has to um give up
as it were trying to formulate exactly
how one feels using language
i mean i should say um i mean this is in
response i think
to something fred said i don't think
language stands alone
i mean if if if you're a student of
language or linguistics or philosophy of
language or whatever
you'd take this phenomenon of exchange
of information then realize a whole lot
more can go on
simply exchange of information commands
can be given etc etc
feelings expressed um but of course
that's never all that's going on when
language is used i mean i was very
struck by this actually by reading
um the norwegian um
canaan god um he was giving an account
of what
went on at um hitler's
campaign rallies as it were um
and his thought was that actually what
was said
what i mean if she transcribed it was
utterly
was more or less irrelevant to what was
going on
i mean what he was doing was whipping up
emotions
in order that um people should think
that there was a
a better world without politics free
from the usual constraints of
rationality etc etc
and that was what they found immensely
attractive and that was how he came to
have so much power
so this was the suggestion i mean i
don't know anything about it was written
in the context of thinking about um what
uh trump might have done on the 6th of
february
that's why there was this discussion um
but i'm sure he got something right so
as it were
language was being used but much more
was going on
than one could possibly know about
by reading the words that was said
but those goings on were still in
principle describable by language
you would say i i actually looked up um
a bit of the
canals called um and
i think he thought that what was going
on escaped analysis
so he was able to tell one as it were
the state of mind in which those
listening
to a national socialist campaigner
um the state of mind that people
listening to such a one
came to be in um
and of course he used words but it isn't
as though those were the words that were
being used by the person who was putting
them into their
mind yeah i get you regarding your own
your own theory of action jennifer um
you you make an argument that to me is
eminently linguistic and the point to
try to make is that
actions are not just bodily movements
right actions take place
underneath the skin so to say um
and and your argument for that is based
on the idea of transitive
and intransitive verbs is that incorrect
what i just said
no i think um you know
just like said we used language in the
world i think we act in the world
um so and it would be perfectly wrong to
think that
um we had even started on the count of
action by saying actions are bodily
movements
though of course philosophers who are
interested in philosophy of action
think they're interested in as they
might put it
mental physical connections so bodily
movement comes to the fore
because when one's acting one's body's
out to something not
so to speak just one's mind but not
that's
necessarily a good way of move of
thinking about it but it explains why
someone
why a philosopher might say all actions
are bodily movements as
as indeed some philosophers have but
that was precisely my point
um the question is a much broader almost
metaphysical question right
are actions uh an external reflection of
inner intent or not
and what's what strikes me was at least
in the the first
jennifer went about it with a linguistic
argument to address what was in
principle a metaphysical question
and that to me was very striking because
it seemed to put
language at the very forefront of a
world
view um but would you say you
departed from that yeah yeah i mean
i was earlier um meaning to question
your use of inner inner consciousness as
it were
um and of course i can intend
to do something or other and there's
nothing outward to show for it
but i think as long as i'm actually
doing something
i mean i may be doing something trivial
like drinking a cup of coffee or um
making a telephone call i i think my
intention is
so to speak therein it's outer what i'm
doing i'm doing intentionally
if i i can't resist this i i have to ask
you this um
the original wittgenstein would adopt
the correspondence theory of truth
right i mean you can make statements and
if those statements correspond to
external states of affair
affairs then those statements are
correct otherwise they're not correct
um the later wittgenstein uh basically
said all philosophy is just language
games
all philosophical problems are language
problems
they have no objective existence they
don't need to be solved they are not out
there
it's stuff we make up uh with our use of
words
how would you see the present jennifer
the mature jennifer in relation to that
change in
wittgenstein's view of philosophical
problems and language
yeah i think the early bit constant the
one who wrote the tranquitatus
um was
um how should i put this interested in
symbolic
systems right whereas the later
wittgenstein and you've used the notion
of the language game was interested in
language as we actually know it um so
if i wanted to say stuff in philosophy
of language i'd been much more likely to
want to say such things as the late of
wickenstein the one
who of the investigations said but then
wouldn't that
imply that the meaning of every word
is dependent on the meaning of other
words
which sort of relativizes language
completely and
makes it difficult to say whether
language can
actually capture objective facts that
the meaning of what you say is dependent
on the meaning of the other words
involved in the game they are not
absolute they are
they are relative they depend on that
network of
interrelated meanings um
to me my interpretation and i am the
first to admit that my interpretation
can be
completely wrong because i'm not really
a wittgenstein scholar
but what what the contrast i see between
my understanding of what wittgenstein
meant
there and what i picked up from you
today is that you seem to attribute
more definite meaning to words as
opposed to
a relative meaning the meaning they have
when they are included in
in a network in a web of words that give
each other relative meaning
yeah i don't know um
that i want to to speak of relative
meaning
but i think
um one should think because i guess
frankenstein wanted to
to think of language as a whole in
trying to
say something about the playing of
language games
as he put it yeah one at a time
i mean i think if i talked about the
meaning of words earlier it was because
you were
asking me questions about that and i you
know i don't think
it's wrong to say concerning any
particular word
that it has some meaning um ordinarily
um
one can say what a word means easily
enough sometimes one if someone doesn't
know them anyone has to
um go go to other word
resort to other words to explain their
meaning um
but i don't think that that makes the
meaning
relative as it were so you do attribute
two words a definite um
i will use the word absolute but i don't
mean it in a super metaphysical sense i
just mean it as
a non-relative you do think our words
have non-relative meaning
so they do capture an objective state of
affairs whether it's true or not
can be verified uh but
our words don't depend on the implicit
words we have
in the networks of meaning in our own
minds
like what i may mean by god depends on
what i mean by a number of other words
like transcendence spirit
uh matter causality all that gives
relative meaning to the word god as i
use it or in the context i use it
but you would say well words beyond that
should have very well grounded definite
meaning
fred no i think is there
any way a objective reality
aren't we all people that live in a
different
place in a different time and we look at
from a perspective
and we can if we check if we sit on one
side of the table
table we might have a kind of same
idea about what we saw even then
it our observation may be handicapped
because one person may have fever
and the other person is sneezing
so it is very i think i've always
struggled with the idea of what is
objective the more precise you
go into details
the more difficult it is to see what is
common ground in objectivity
so i i but but jennifer
something comes up you being an expert
on words
um i i realize that
we humans are one of the millions of
forms of expression on this planet
and as i think to know
we are the only ones that help our
communication
to do it as well in words but
in when it relates to information
exchange but
ants bees trees
dogs or birds or they all communicate
all the time with one another without
words they share information fields
um so we are quite an in
an exemption and that comes sometimes to
the thought how would it be
if we keep on behaving like babies
and not use words of course it's a
rather abstract
question but it was just an idea
that comes up right now i think it's
characteristic of human beings
to be language users and i think that
goes in hand with their
um the kind of knowledge that they can
have
as it were um
for instance of the past i mean
think how much we know by virtue of
being able to say
what happened um that's unique yeah
yeah yeah i mean i think we are
very much unique as a species
but we're not unique in in some sense
communicating
um having others yeah having others
come by bits of information because
others have
done something by virtue of which they
know it
i'll ask you a more concrete question
what
can philosophy tell us about the darker
side of language how
how it can be used to lie mislead and
manipulate people what what what do you
think about that
it's sometimes i mean in recent years
it's come to amaze
me how ready people are to believe what
they hear when
manifestly as far as i'm concerned what
they hear is simply a lie
and i think they're all kinds of ways
actually not simply by lying
that um language is implicated in
um what people
at large come to know say within a
political system
so i i was actually reading something
recently about
um someone who talked about his
experience as a
politician he's now he was a member of
the conservative party and i well i'm
sure he's still a member but now
no longer um uh
is any sort of minister but he was
saying that what went on in discussion
was a failure to say what was obvious
because there were obvious things
which needed to be brought into the
discussion when one would have thought
needed
but they didn't want those things to be
known
yeah i think there are all kinds of ways
in which language can be used
specifically perhaps by politicians to
manipulate
what's known by the community um
but i don't think i need to be a
philosopher to be in a position to
see that that goes on do you think we
we think in language uh jennifer is
there a tight relationship you think
between
grammatical syntactical structures and
the way we reason
and we think about things yeah i think
we're
we're language users and we're concept
using creatures as it were
there's then a question how one uses the
word thought because
some of the things fred was asking me
were requiring me to think of
animals as thinkers and i think one does
have to think as it were that they do
things
um because things of us and so and of
course if i'm human i can say
how things were which led me to do such
and such
so um there's use of the word thought so
that
um it's very hard not to attach it to
animals um nonetheless i think ordinary
we think of
when we think of thought we think of
human thought
we think you can't have such thought um
save that you're human that's to say a
language user
we know uh jennifer that language sort
of evolves right i mean english today is
totally different than 9th
century english to the point that no
english speaker today would
have any idea of ninth century english
it was completely different and that
happens in
all languages where do you see
language going um in the future how will
it evolve and how do you think that will
impact
our way of life our world view how we
interact with one another is there
interplay there and if there is
where do you see this going long term i
mean i'm sure language
will change and and i think actually um
at least if one's thinking about english
new words as they're called things which
um dictionary makers have to add to
their dictionaries
um get added at a rate that they never
would have done
um say 50 years ago so i'm sure that the
evolution of language which presumably
goes hand in hand with the
evolution of um stuff that people find
themselves needing to want to say
um is um increasing a pace
as it were but quite where um
it's leading i don't know and do you
think there is a correlation between
that evolution and how society itself
evolves our values
our ways of interacting with one another
i think if um
uh words which are derogatory of groups
of people
were eliminated from the language we'd
live in a better world but of course i
don't
i don't see um how it could be
that those words came to be eliminated
except that there weren't groups of
people who
um for instance we're racist
so we could progress but um there are
many variables at play here and we can't
uh wrestle control over the future
evolution of language and
and society jennifer it's been a
pleasure
to speak to you today i wish we had more
time but we have to leave it here today
we are very grateful for your
participation and maybe we look forward
to speaking
speaking to you again another time in
the future thanks a lot good
thank you thank you and thank you also
to fred
thank you very much jennifer we hope
you've enjoyed this conversation
we will be back in a few weeks with
episode 4
on growth until next time for more
debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of art and ideas at iai tv
you